[Music]
foreign
I have neglected to mention until this
moment that this week is transgender
awareness week which leads us up to
transgender Remembrance Day and it's
important that we have this week and
that day to become aware of and remember
trans people just as it's crucial that
we have LGBT pride month and LGBT
history month and LGBT Spirit day and
pronoun awareness day and International
Day against homophobia transphobia and
biphobia and so on it's clear that there
is not a special
um that if there is not a special
holiday recognizing and calling
attention to LGBT people and especially
trans people and if we don't have this
holiday at least twice a month then we
will all forget that these people exist
and they will immediately evaporate
it'll be like that show the leftovers
which is a great show by the way
depicting an apocalyptic scenario where
a large portion of the Earth's
population suddenly vanishes Without a
Trace
and the creator of that show never said
this explicitly but it's clear that it
was supposed to be a parable about what
will happen if we don't have enough LGBT
awareness days so we must always remain
aware we must make sure that everyone
else is aware that the LGBT Club stays
at the center of everything always no
matter what forever
and so to that end the men's World Cup
team is doing its part
providing further evidence that soccer
is gay uh the men's team has redesigned
their official Crest to get rid of the
American flag colors and instead
incorporate the rainbow flag from The
Daily Mail it says the United States is
uh the United States Men's National Team
have made a huge statement at the world
topic Guitar World Cup of Guitar by
redesigning their Crest to incorporate
the rainbow flag in a bid to show
solidarity with the lgbtq plus Community
the tournament which starts on Sunday
and sees the U.S play their opener
against Wales on Monday has been hugely
controversial in its build up given
qatar's human rights record and attitude
to human sexual homosexuality as
recently as this month a Qatar World Cup
Ambassador told a German TV broadcaster
that homosexuality was damaged to the
mind and it remains illegal to be gay in
the conservative Muslim country the usmt
appeared to have made an immediate stand
on their arrival in Doha though by
changing their usual red stripes on
their Crest to a rainbow around their
team base pictures from the AL garafa SC
stadium and our our Ryan
where the U.S has trained on Monday
showed a huge U.S Crest on the wall
alongside the slogan One Nation it has
understood the crest on the team's kits
on the field won't be changed but the
new colors will be shown off at their
practice facilities
so as you can see the Crest is actually
an example really of trans Erasure
rather than trans awareness as it only
includes the colors on the old LGBT flag
that's the bigoted hateful LGBT flag of
our ancestors the one that looks tacky
but lacks the boldness and courage to be
totally chaotic and vomitous and hideous
like you know a unicorn vomited all over
it as of course the current
trans-inclusive flag looks
yet fortunately the other colors are
represented elsewhere in their practice
facility after all it's not just about
the crest you know U.S soccer is doing
an entire LGBT Rebrand reading more from
The Daily Mail says Neil buth the USM
nt's Chief Communications officer told
dailymail.com our rainbow badge has an
important and consistent role in the
identity of U.S soccer as part of our
approach for any match or event we
include rainbow branding to support and
embrace the lgbtq community as well as
to promote a spirit of inclusiveness and
welcoming to all fans across the globe
as a result locations that we will
manage and operate at the FIFA World Cup
such as the team Hotel Media areas and
parties will feature both traditional
rainbow U.S soccer branding so it will
have the traditional flag and also the
rainbow flag
does it make sense that the same company
who controls half of online retail also
eavesdrops on your private conversations
at home whether the company that
controls 90 of all internet searches
also runs your email service and tracks
everything you do on your smartphone
well big Tech is more powerful than most
countries these days and they profit by
exploiting your personal data put a
layer of protection between your online
activity and big Tech with expressvpn
think about how much of your life is on
the internet every site you visit video
you watch message you send it all gets
tracked and data mined but when you run
expressvpn on your device the software
hide your IP address making your
activity a lot more difficult to trace
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
internet data to keep you safe from
hackers and eavesdroppers what I like
most about expressvpn is how easy it is
to use download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button and you're
protected it's as simple as that
expressvpn does all of this without
slowing your connection stop handing
over your personal data to the big Tech
Monopoly who mines your activity and
sells your information protect yourself
with the VPN that I trust to keep me
safe online visit expressvpn.com Matt
wall show and get three extra months for
free that's expressvpn.com mattwallshow
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show
now you may point out that if U.S soccer
is actually concerned about qatar's
record on quote LGBT rights
they could make a much greater statement
by refusing to participate in the World
Cup in the first place
I mean by simply showing up and
participating they are financially
supporting the country that they claim
to be protesting against
which is a bit like protesting JK
Rowling by buying a Harry Potter book
and then burning it I mean you've
already bought the book or protesting
Elon Musk by buying a Tesla and then
running it into a telephone pole on
purpose you've already given your
financial support it's a little bit too
late whatever statement you make in the
process or afterwards is now irrelevant
but then of course this is the whole
point of virtue signaling that's why we
call it virtue signaling not virtue
doing
we don't call it virtue doing because
there is no virtue involved here in
first place and also because nothing is
being done
the corporate gay pride stuff is all
just sheep's Blood on the door signaling
that they are the chosen people so that
the angel of cancellation passes them
over
but as far as symbolism goes
I think it is appropriate that they
should replace the colors of the
American flag with the colors of the
LGBT flag I mean it's horrendous it's
traitorous it's treasonous
if I was in charge of the country they
wouldn't be in they wouldn't be allowed
back into the country
but
it's also appropriate because the LGBT
Nation
LGBT a stand we may call it is after all
the country that Corporate America as
well as the United States government
seeks to represent it is the nation that
the left pledges allegiance to
it is the country that wishes to
colonize the world and export its ideas
and values to corners of the globe that
have no interest in them
now I've often said that the alphabet
Club is a religious cult
and it is that certainly
but maybe on second thought it's better
understood in this way as a country
it has its own flag
its own national holidays its own myths
and traditions its own sports teams
and it has its own government too which
is formerly known as the United States
government
now some people predict that we will
eventually in the future become two
countries you know there's gonna be some
kind of Civil War
the point is that we're already two
countries
there's one that salutes the pride flag
and despises the American flag and one
that salutes the American flag and has
no use for the pride flag
at this point it's only a matter of
making the split official I suppose
something that we will probably never do
but we should
and that is why U.S soccer is today
canceled though really a lot of
unnecessary words there because U.S
soccer is already canceled because it's
soccer
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]